[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Everything in
the world was done
to me that would've killed me.
And here I am alive.
- From the Auschwitz experiments
of the Angel of Death--
- Children!
Children-- at Auschwitz.
- Through decades of
isolation and anger--
- I accuse the world
of stopping to care!
- Eva is tough.
- Bloody-minded.
- Gestapo!
Gestapo!
- She rose to introduce the
Mengele twins to the world--
- She woke us all up.
- Launched the biggest
manhunt in history.
- The worldwide search
for this war criminal
was given new
importance this week.
- Eva's role was
absolutely critical.
- Forgive mankind's worst crime.
- I, Eva Moses Kor, hereby
give amnesty to all Nazis--
- I said you're
going to do what?
You're going to do what?
- How could she possibly,
possibly forgive?
- Free herself and start
a worldwide movement.
- Forgive your worst enemy.
It will heal your soul,
and it will set you free.
- I just wanted to
stand up and applaud.
- It was like [? you meet ?]
[? of ?] an angel.
- The pathway out
of a dark place.
- A revelation of
what's possible
in the human condition.
- Even when we're
all long gone--
- We are free!
- --they'll still
be telling a story.
- We are free!
- By any standards
of the imagination--
- What an astounding journey.
- The story of Eva.
- She's taking you somewhere,
and has taken us somewhere
that we need to
be prepared to go.
[END PLAYBACK]
SPEAKER 1: All right, so thank
you, Ted, even for being here.
Ted, let's start with you.
How did you get
introduced to Eva,
and decide to take
on this project?
TED GREEN: Well, I
live in Indianapolis
right by Butler University.
And one day I'm sitting at
home in the late afternoon,
and a friend of mine from
Butler calls and says,
hey, I got your next one.
I got your next film.
And I said, well, I'm
working on a film right now.
And he said, no, this is
definitely your next one.
It's about Eva, Eva Kor.
And I said, what's an Eva Kor?
Seriously, I had no
idea who she was.
And he said, she's a
Holocaust survivor.
And I thought, well,
in all honesty,
you know, with all
due respect, there
have been a lot of
Holocaust stories.
What makes this one different?
He said, just trust me.
Come over here.
You'll see for yourself.
She's speaking tonight.
So I go over there, in
a beautiful theater,
2,000 people.
It is absolutely packed.
I sit-in the back.
And like everybody else
there, I am mesmerized
by this woman's story.
I mean, she's there.
She's just telling
it straightforward.
And I'm also
mesmerized by the fact
that everybody else is
mesmerized by her as well.
All eyes are right on her.
So I knew this is something
that I really wanted to do.
I waited a few days.
I drove over to her museum
in Terre Haute, Indiana,
just about 70 miles away.
And I kind of had to pitch her.
And to be honest,
in all honesty,
she was pretty
skeptical at first.
I mean, to be involved in
one of these documentaries
takes a lot of work.
So I broke out the old charm,
charmed her for a while.
Isn't that right?
Little bit of charm.
Yeah, maybe.
It took a little
while, but she said--
we settled on this.
She said, why don't
you come with me
on the trip to Auschwitz,
and see what you think.
And so I went with my
co-producer, Mika Brown,
and others from our
production team.
And we spent a week there.
And I ought to say I went
in as a hardened journalist,
and I thought that this was,
you know, the tough guy,
and this is just
another story to cover.
And after three days,
I was crying along
with everybody else.
It was a life-changing trip.
It's a life-changing
place to go.
And I believe Eva's, once I
really started to learn it,
is a life-changing story.
I mean, you have to see
that this is a woman,
this is just a--
her story is a stunning
psychological odyssey
that has played out
so very publicly,
and is rooted in the worst
event in modern times,
and now finds this 84-year-old
woman in a walker traveling
the world to preach about
healing and forgiveness
and humanity.
There are a lot of
ingredients there.
And I was really
honored to take it on.
SPEAKER 1: So Eva, let's
have you tell your story.
I know you speak all over
the country, really all
over the world.
And I've been fortunate enough
to see your presentation
a few times.
Unfortunately not enough time
for the whole thing today, but
can you talk about
your time at Auschwitz
and surviving with your sister,
especially with Dr. Mengele?
EVA KOR: After four years of
Hungarian Nazi occupation,
four days in a cattle
car without water,
just very little air.
On the cattle car, doors opened.
We had no idea where we were.
And within 30 minutes, my
whole family was ripped apart.
Miriam and I were standing
on the selection platform,
holding onto one another.
We did not know what
would happen to us.
We were completely bewildered.
We became part of a group
of little girls, all twins.
There were 13 sets of
twins and one mother.
One thing that I need to
explain from the beginning.
From the time that we arrived
in Auschwitz, actually
from the time we were put in
the cattle car to the time
we were liberated, no one
ever told us where we were,
why we were there, and
what would happen to us.
So everything was going
on as it was happening.
The first night we were in
the barrack that is there,
crude and filthy,
three-story-high bunk beds
with a bench in the middle,
a brick bench in the middle,
infested with lice and rats.
We were starved for food.
We were starved
for human kindness.
We were starved for the love of
the mothers and fathers we once
had.
We had no rights.
And somehow we had the fierce
determination, which I still
do not understand where it came
from, to live one more day,
survive one more experiment.
I was used in two
types of experiments.
After roll call-- every morning
and night we had the roll call
at 6:00 AM and 6:00 PM--
then Mengele would
come in the barrack
to count us in the morning.
Then we got breakfast.
There was a brownish cup of
liquid, bitter, lukewarm cold
coffee, zero calories.
Then we would be
taken for experiments.
Monday, Wednesday,
and Friday, we
would be placed naked in a
room for about eight hours.
They would measure
every part of my body,
compare it to my twin
sister's and compare it
to a [? chart. ?]
These were not
dangerous experiments.
But even in Auschwitz,
they were very demeaning
because they made me feel like
I was a nothing and nobody.
So the only way I could
cope with it after a while
is blocking it out of my mind.
The other experiments were on
Tuesday, Thursday and Saturday,
where they would
take us to a lab
that I named the
"Blood Lab," tie
both of my arms to
restrict the blood flow.
Take a lot of blood
from my left arm.
Give me a minimum of five
injections into my right arm.
The content of those
injections we didn't know then,
nor do I know today.
The rumor was that they were
germs, diseases, and drugs.
After one of the injections,
I became very ill
with a very high fever.
I was trembling as the August
sun was burning my skin.
Arms and legs were
swollen and painful.
And I was covered with red dots.
Next visit to the Blood Lab they
did, instead of tying my arms,
they measured my fever, and
I knew I was in trouble.
I was taken to the hospital.
It was filled with people who
they looked to me more dead
than alive.
Next morning, Mengele
arrived with four doctors.
Never examined me.
He looked at my fever
chart, and then he
declared, laughing
sarcastically, "Too bad.
She's so young.
She has only two weeks to live."
I knew he was right
but I refused to die.
So I made a second
silent pledge that I
will do whatever
is within my power
to prove Dr. Mengele wrong,
to survive and be reunited
with my twin sister, Miriam.
For the following two weeks,
I have only one clear memory.
I remember crawling
on the barrack floor
because I couldn't walk.
And I was crawling to
reach a faucet with water
because this barrack was
not even allocated water.
After two weeks, my fever
broke, and I immediately
felt a lot stronger.
And it took me
another three weeks.
So I was in the hospital of
the barrack of the living
dead, I call, for five weeks.
I was released and reunited
with my twin sister, Miriam.
What I skipped over,
and I want to reiterate
because it was very important--
that first night when we
couldn't go back to our bunk
beds because the rats were
parading right at the bottom,
and our bunk beds on the bottom,
and we went to the latrine,
and I saw three dead children
on the barrack floor.
I have never seen
anybody dead before.
But that hit me very
severely, violently,
to see dead children
on the floor.
So that was my
first silent pledge.
Then I said, I will do anything
and everything within my power
to make sure that Miriam and I
shall not end up on that filthy
latrine floor, that we actually
would survive and walk out
of this camp alive.
And that idea, that mindset that
followed me throughout my days
in Auschwitz, I wonder if
I would have never seen
those dead bodies,
would I have been
able to make that decision.
Because whatever was wrong, I
was going to somehow survive.
And so I survived.
I was released from the
barracks of the living dead.
My sister was quite
sick in the barrack,
but she was never
taken to the hospital.
Life in Auschwitz, for instance,
I want to kind of just--
today, 74 years ago,
I was in Auschwitz.
And I was just
trying to reminisce.
It might have been
the day that we were--
once a week, usually on Friday,
we were taken to the showers
to actually give us soap.
And we washed with the soap.
Actually, I figured out, I
was in Auschwitz 255 days.
And we found out later it
was made out of human fat.
It had very low
[INAUDIBLE] to it.
We were walking with
our soap, because you
were given it in the barrack,
and we passed the shower.
And there was a chill
going through all of us.
Why did we go further
than the shower room?
Next, camp was B. We were
in camp A. There was the gas
chambers and crematoriums.
And they told us-- some
people said that they sometime
had these tricks.
They would tell you to take a
shower, and you end up in the--
and they did go.
We finally entered the
shower room in camp B.
And we kept thinking, what
will come from up there?
Came water.
What a relief that was.
Because what we found out later
on that the camps and shower,
in camp A the showers
in camp A were broken.
That is-- but nobody
explained to us anything.
It was always done
as it happened.
And life was that way in
the camp at all times.
Never any information
of what will happen
or how we are going to--
we never even knew for
the 255 days in Auschwitz.
We never knew how we are
going to be liberated.
I can tell you one thing
that was a great help for me.
Late in August, one day
there was an airplane
flying over the camp.
That was the first time.
It was flying low.
I could see the American
flag on one of the wings.
That gave me hope that
somebody was trying to free us.
And hope in Auschwitz
was in very short supply.
There was no one to talk
to and ask, why was there
American airplane?
None of us knew.
And the grown ups
didn't talk to us.
The supervisor didn't.
The air raids continued
and increased.
And every time they were
bombing, we were applauding.
Because that meant the
Nazis will be defeated,
and we will win, and
we would be free.
And that went on.
By November we had
three air raids a day.
All the experiments stopped.
And we could tell that
this cannot go on forever.
But we're just going
to hope that somehow we
survive until the
liberation will happen.
And that happened
late January, 1945.
We were free.
We were alive.
And it was an unbelievable day.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you
for sharing this story.
There's a part of the story
that Ted really highlights
that hasn't been told as much.
And so Ted, I kind
of want to go to you
and talk a little
bit about the time
when he was in Indiana,
and shortly after,
and she'd been liberated.
And there was a lot
of anger and stuff
that she hasn't talked
about as much about
and that you capture
in the video.
How did you get to
tell the whole story?
TED GREEN: Well, first I
would really like, again,
to think Eva and her CANDLES
Museum, because they allowed
us to travel with Eva
all over the world, which
gave us wonderful insight.
We were able to do
an interview with her
in her tiny, little Romania,
Transylvania town of ports,
in the one-room schoolhouse
where she and her twin sister
Miriam were forced to
kneel on corn kernels
while all the other
kids made fun of them
and called them dirty Jews.
We were able to interview
her in the blood lab
that she was talking about
where they had blood drawn,
and they gave the
mysterious injections.
We were able to interview
her at the graveside
of her twin, Miriam, in
Ashkelon Cemetery in Israel.
And we were also able-- this
is a real highlight, I think,
for a lot of us-- we were
able to interview her
on a tiny little boat
off the port of Haifa,
where, in 1950,
she and her sister
and a whole bunch
of other refugees
really first tasted freedom.
And they all stood up and
they sang the Israeli National
Anthem.
And so, of course, Eva on
the boat just impromptu
breaks into singing it.
So we were able to be with
her in these super important
places, which helps open up.
But yes, in a deeper sense,
the reason we were able to do--
to get to that new
side of the story
was because of her courage.
She had the courage to
open up to us things
that she really hadn't
opened up much about before.
I believe, generally,
her story before
had been told in two parts, what
I call part one and part three.
Part one being her
time at Auschwitz,
part three being her
forgiveness, which was in 1995.
Well, there's 50-- exactly a
half century in the middle that
was--
it was extremely
painful for Eva.
And that's why she didn't like
to talk about it very much.
It included a really
ugly hard-to-watch arrest
in the US capitol.
And so this was very
troubling for her.
But she did open up to us.
And I think that
what that showed
is that it ultimately
showed what kind of set
the stage for the forgiveness
that would change her life,
and has, in turn,
changed, I would
say, hundreds of
thousands of lives
since then through
the work she's doing.
So really, it was
through her courage
that we were able to
get that full story out.
SPEAKER 1: And Eva, I want you
to talk about the forgiveness
piece.
But how did you come to,
and I guess, why did you
decide to open up to Ted about
this painful part of your life?
EVA KOR: Number one,
talking about forgiveness
is a very positive thing.
And it is easier than talking
about the painful things.
And when I talk
about forgiveness,
it is difficult to mix the
trauma that I experienced
in the United States
with the forgiveness
because it makes it very long.
The other thing that
nobody asked me in detail
what Ted asked me.
So well, the old question,
if you don't ask,
you don't get to answer.
He was very determined.
And he researched it.
And his questions
were clear-cut,
and there was no other way
but to enter them straight on.
Also, I did not
really know how far
he was going to go with that.
As I like to tell him,
you're digging into my soul,
and I don't like it.
Because these
soul-diggings are painful.
And we don't really want
to get every morning up
and think about the worst
experiences in our life.
And particularly living
in the United States,
one would not think that
my pain was continuing.
And it was continuing to
a very, very big extent,
to be realizing that I
think that the two best
governments under which I lived
were Israel and the United
States, but they
are not perfect.
None of them are perfect.
I mean, I have suffered
here in the United States
from things that might have
happened that the government
has done or people have done.
That is a very touchy
thing to talk about.
I don't really like to talk.
I don't want to accuse the
United States of not doing
the right thing every time.
But sometimes they're not.
Sometimes they make mistakes.
I was asking too many questions.
And so that is a
reason that I never
really wanted to talk about it.
But I wanted answers.
The fact that the United
States was so interested
in the Mengele case, in
one way it was hopeful.
Maybe they will give
us answers, too, right?
But then they never
gave us any answers.
They just gave us decisions.
And when the decision
in 1985 in June--
we just went to
Auschwitz in 1985
with the first
group of survivors
to celebrate 40 years to
the liberation of the camp.
And we made headlines
throughout the world.
As a result of that,
the Attorney General,
I think his name was Smith,
opened the airport in trying
to find Mengele and arrest him.
So then by June, the
United States government
had a report that
Mengele's bones
were found in Embu, Brazil.
They talked to many
Holocaust organizations
in the United States, many
politicians, but not us,
the twins, who were
directly affected by it.
And that was my protest
in Washington DC.
I felt that they should-- if it
is important to United States,
that they should have an
open hearing in Washington,
and not just give
that determination.
And I knew that nobody
would like me to protest,
but they saw my little cardboard
that was 8 by 20 cardboard.
I hand wrote it, that the
memory services are not enough.
We need an open hearing
on Mengele [? gate. ?]
They let me through
the security.
And then when I held it
up, they arrested me,
but it was the brutality of
it that was really startling,
scary.
And then as the detective
who came on my right shoulder
and actually ripped
my rotator cuff,
and this is when
I began to scream.
It really hurt.
So why I didn't talk,
and why I talk about now,
it's never pleasant.
It's never pleasant.
And I knew that I know
that they knew that.
But the tools truth
might be able to help.
Maybe we can put that to rest.
And people don't see
that their life is just
a bowl of peaches and cream.
Life is a struggle.
But to go from
here, actually, I am
convinced that if I would
have never been arrested,
I would have never
forgiven the Nazis.
Because from there on--
I also wanted answers because
my sister was so very ill.
So I was doing
everything I could
do to find as much information
about Mengele's experiments.
And did not end up with
a lot of good results.
But in order to go on,
we need to really know
as much as possible.
And then realizing that
I was not going to get--
and can you imagine
for one moment,
I am in the capitol rotunda--
I want to describe it to you--
surrounded by all the members
of Congress, by 15 or 100
to 1,000 survivors,
by the world press,
probably 1,000 members
of the world press.
Not anybody got up or
asked, what on earth
are they doing to her?
Not anybody ever contacted
me after the arrest.
Are you alive or dead?
That was very scary
to me, that that
could happen, that people
who I expected to help me--
my fellow survivors, the
government of United States,
and the press--
nobody did.
That made me feel that
from there on, I said,
I was afraid to
go to Washington.
But strangely, I'm not
afraid to go to Auschwitz.
What does that mean?
That doesn't make any sense.
And when the
opportunity presented
itself to meet with the
Nazi doctor in 1993,
I was very, very nervous.
I was very worried.
What I remembered about Nazis,
I wasn't looking forward to it.
But when I met him, this
was a guy I was scared of,
and he was treating
me with respect.
And the people who were supposed
to treat me with respect
were arresting me
and ignoring me.
Something didn't end up.
And that is a way I think
the mind is interesting,
how it works.
I don't know if I want to talk
about forgiveness right now.
SPEAKER 1: No, go--
yeah, it's the next question.
EVA KOR: Well, the
idea is that I asked--
I met with the doctor.
He was willing to
tell me everything.
And basically it
was to have a report
I could take to a
conference in Boston,
because he was not
willing to go to Boston.
And the camera people were
wrapping up everything,
and we were sitting outside.
It was a nice August afternoon.
August 20, 1993.
And I didn't really plan
to ask that question,
but somehow it
popped into my head.
Dr. Munch, you
were in Auschwitz.
Did you ever walk
by the gas chamber?
Did you ever go inside?
Do you know how it operates?
And he said, yes, yes, yes.
This is a nightmare that I
live with every single day
of my life.
And then he went on describing
the operation of the gas
chamber.
He said that everybody-- he
was not in the gas chamber.
He was stationed outside and
looking through a peephole.
And then everybody was dead.
I signed their
death certificates.
No names.
Just the number of
people that were killed.
I have never read
about it in any book.
So I told him that was new
information I didn't know.
And therefore, I invited him to
go with me to Auschwitz in 1995
to sign a document at
the ruins of the gas
chamber in the
company of witnesses,
just what he told me.
And I wanted six
witnesses so nobody
could say later on that he
didn't sign this document.
And he said, I would love to.
I was pleased that
it was so easy.
I got back to Terre Haute.
And I wanted to thank this
Nazi doctor for his willingness
to document the gas chamber.
What I liked about it that
it was not a Jewish person.
Because Jews are being accused
of inventing the Holocaust.
It was important
to me that this was
a Nazi who witnessed it
and was willing to testify.
And I wanted to thank him,
and that was a strange thing.
Because I realized thanking the
Nazis, that was a crazy idea.
So I did not tell
anybody about it,
because I didn't want my friends
and family to talk me out
of it.
So I did not know
how to thank a Nazi.
And I didn't know where to turn.
For the 10 months, every day,
I brainstormed by myself.
And after 10 months, a simple
idea popped into my head.
How about a letter of
forgiveness from me
to Dr. Munch.
I realized that that
was a meaningful gift.
But what I discovered for
myself was that I had the power
to forgive.
No one can give me that power.
No one can take it away.
It was all mine to use
in any way I wished.
And so that is a way
I arrived in Auschwitz
with Dr. Munch and my children.
Alex was with me and
my daughter Rena.
And I don't think that they
really understood how big that
was for me, to realize
as time goes on--
and I am doing a lot
more research on it,
and I am going to write a little
book just about forgiveness,
my forgiveness.
Because people do not
understand that accidentally
I stumbled, in my opinion,
on the cure for war,
the secret to world peace.
If every person, or the
majority of the people,
when they are
hurt, they know how
to heal themselves by forgiving,
there is no anger in the world.
People concentrate on getting
along and doing good things
rather than killing each
other or getting evil.
And the forgiveness
doesn't hurt anybody.
It always helps the victims.
That is not designed to do.
I did not forgive ultimately
to help Dr. Munch.
It started out as a
gift to Dr. Munch.
But it ended up as a
curing of my own pain.
And many people have contacted
me to tell me the same thing.
SPEAKER 1: So Ted, you
got to kind of experience
the other side of somewhat
of a controversial message.
How, when you talk to the other
twins, the other survivors,
how did they take to the
[? messes ?] of forgiving
a Nazi?
TED GREEN: Well, I
would have to say
that most survivors, probably
a pretty heavy percentage,
really, absolutely disagree
with Eva's forgiveness.
You saw one woman
there, a lovely woman,
in the trailer,
whose veins were kind
of popping out of her head,
she was so enraged about it.
We were able to interview the
only set of twins still alive
who were with Eva
in her barrack.
And they have this great
love with Eva and bond.
But they also adamantly
disagree with her.
So yeah, that's something
to sit down and take in.
I think there are two--
a couple of things, the
main points they have,
is that how can she
forgive and forget.
And then that's
just flat-out wrong.
The last thing she is
doing is forgetting.
I would say that there is
no other survivor alive
who is working harder
day to day, year to year,
to keep the messages
of the Holocaust
alive as much as this
woman right here.
They also say that
while forgiveness
is OK for maybe lesser crimes,
for maybe one on one crimes,
but the Holocaust,
that's too much,
that's simply unforgivable.
I think I can--
this is what Eva would say
is it's not unforgivable.
And in fact, in
the documentary, we
were fortunate to interview
an expert on forgiveness.
He wrote the book
"Embodying Forgiveness."
He's the former Dean of
the Duke Divinity School.
And he says that
for Eva to forgive
the seemingly unforgivable
proves that it's not
unforgivable after all.
That we all sort of have
to look within ourselves
and try to figure out why
couldn't we forgive something
that big.
And it's a tough question.
And I'm not here to
advocate or not advocate.
I'm here to chronicle.
But I will say that
I have also have
been able to interview so many
people whose lives have been
changed, in some cases saved,
by Eva through her forgiveness.
SPEAKER 1: And Ted, what's
next for the project?
TED GREEN: Well,
it's actually kind
of an exciting time right now.
We are in the process of--
we're negotiating for national
distribution right now.
We are entering into
lots of film festivals.
We've already gotten into a few.
We've received screenings so
far, dozens of screenings,
from around-- requests
from around the country.
And one thing I want to say is
we're very proud of-- we just
released an
educational tool kit,
which is a cut-down version
of the film-- one hour--
along with a curriculum
guide that's standards-based,
and really, really works.
And we are spreading
that nationwide as well,
along with the help of
Tanglewood Publishing,
the publisher of Eva's book.
So to follow along,
to see our progress,
and to see clips
of the film and all
that, we are turning everybody
to our website, which
is www.thestoryofEva.com.
SPEAKER 1: So I want to open
it up to audience questions.
So we have two
microphones on each side.
While people are lining up, Eva,
I've got a question for you.
The last couple of
years, you've become
a little bit of a celebrity.
You were the Grand
Marshal of the Indy 500.
You've become friends with
Ray Allen and Motley Crue
and all kinds of people.
Who's your favorite
celebrity that you've
got to meet the last few years?
EVA KOR: It's a very
incorrect question to ask me.
I like all celebrities
and actually
all people who are interested
in learning about the Holocaust,
learning about forgiveness.
It is each person
relates to it different.
Ray Allen is a member of
the US Holocaust Council,
and he has a special
interest in it.
Then I met him, this tall guy.
With all his family, he
came to Miami to my lecture.
And he was interested
in what I had to say.
I was very surprised
that he brought
all of his five children.
And with Motley Crew it
was strange, very strange.
Nikki Sixx, his burley hair
appeared above my shoulder,
as he was putting his
arm on my shoulder.
And I saw this dangling
arm with all the tattoos.
And I didn't even
know where on earth I
was, because I just turned
around on the red carpet
to find the right direction.
You were there.
TED GREEN: I was there.
EVA KOR: And I'm
trying to figure out
what on earth is happening.
And he smiles with his big
mustache and lots of hair.
"Hi, sweetie."
I'm saying, well, I'm
on the red carpet.
What do I do?
I said hi.
And then everybody told
me he was this famous.
Well, I have texted to him
later on, a year later, I said,
you scared me to death.
Lucky that you had a nice smile.
That put me at ease.
I mean, I did not--
I expected to meet media,
maybe in suits or at least
more civilized looking.
TED GREEN: You know,
what you're leaving out
is right after the event, she
tweeted him and said, how do I
get to be a rock star like you?
And he responded--
EVA KOR: "Well,
sweetie, you have
been a rock star all your life.
You have inspired many people."
So then I appeared on his
radio show about a year ago.
But it is-- here we are.
I mean, lots of celebrities.
I need all the celebrities,
I need all the everybody
to join in that effort
to create a better
understanding of how
we can get along,
and how we can heal ourselves.
Nobody can heal you.
You have to work at
healing yourself.
Because it's a personal
journey of actually addressing
what happened, and coming
out on the other side feeling
that you have, I have,
everybody has the right
to be free of any pain that
anybody imposed upon us.
That the survivors don't
agree they are wrong.
They keep telling me, you
can't forgive Nazi atrocities.
Did God say that?
Did God decide that Nazis
are too big to forgive them?
That is man's interpretation.
Why can't you forgive the
big crime that really hurt,
when you can forgive
the small crimes.
I think we should
forgive all crimes,
not for the sake
of the perpetrator,
but for the sake of
healing ourselves.
And once we are
healed, we hope that we
can teach the perpetrators
to heal themselves too.
TED GREEN: Could I jump in
here with one little shameless
promotion, or another
shameless promotion?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, sure.
TED GREEN: To join Eva's team,
we have actually started that
with hashtag #TeamEva.
Anybody who wants to sort
of follow along and join
with this crusade
she's on, please
look at hashtag #TeamEva.
EVA KOR: I want to jump
in also with something,
because I have an app.
It's called Eva-- capital
E-V-A without any space,
and then capital K-O-R.
You can click on it.
You get at least three lectures.
You can choose what
you want to hear.
And you get some
other information.
You can bring it up on your
iPhone anytime you want to.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First of all, thank you
for coming to Google.
I have a question
about forgiveness
and how it might
be different when
the person you are forgiving,
or the people that you
are forgiving, feel bad
versus don't feel bad.
So in the case of the
doctor who you spoke with
and who expressed to you that
he felt terrible every day,
it seems like that would aid in
being able to feel forgiveness,
whereas presumably
there are Nazis who
still are alive who might not--
who don't feel that
way, who don't feel bad.
How do you feel forgiveness
for those people?
EVA KOR: Because of
forgiveness, if we understand it
correctly today--
I agree with you that when it
happened it was helpful to me
that he was feeling sorry and
remorse in what he has done.
If he would have yelled
at me and treated me
like a good old
Nazi in the camp,
I probably would
not have not been
able to reach a
forgiveness or even want
to deal with him at all.
So these steps that happened,
happened accidentally.
But once I realized what the
power that the forgiveness has,
I do not care.
I am sorry if they
feel still angry,
and they want to
create problems.
I have the right.
And it's a fairly selfish thing,
but it does not hurt anybody.
It helps everybody, that
I do have the human right.
And actually, I am
trying to get the United
Nations to change
their Universal
Declaration to Human Rights.
That every human being on
the face of this earth--
an addendum that I
would like to add--
has the human right to be happy
and to be free of the pain
that anybody imposed
us in the past.
And we can do it if we
so choose by forgiving.
So the ideal of
forgiveness, I would
like it to be a human right
included into the declaration.
But the fact that they
are still mean and nasty,
it's more that I have the
need to forgive them, and thus
remove them from my agenda.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
EVA KOR: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you.
So my question is, do you
consider the forgiveness
to the start of the
healing process,
or do you consider possibility
of the healing started before,
even before forgiveness,
and forgiveness
being a stage of that.
EVA KOR: I'm not
sure that I follow.
TED GREEN: Do you need
to forgive-- let's see
if I'm hearing this right.
Do you need to be
able to forgive
before you can start healing?
Or can you heal sometimes
before you forgive?
AUDIENCE: Yes, that's right.
EVA KOR: You have to forgive.
Because by forgiving,
you are removing
all the pain and the burden.
Although, one more thing.
Forgiveness gives you
power over your life.
And most victims when
they are victimized
and after, they
feel they have they
have no power to
change their life.
Many people.
So what can I do about it?
That's it.
But by having that power that
we all do, we exist in every--
even in wars where there is a
lot more problems than here,
we do have the power to forgive.
We don't have to make it public.
But we know that we forgive.
Therefore, the burden of pain
is removed from our shoulder.
And this is when
the healing starts.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you
for coming to speak to us.
As you know, we are
technology builders.
We build telephones and
communications systems,
information tools.
You've been living a
life of great purpose
through a time of great
technological transformation
through the 20th century.
I wonder if you can
think of any time
maybe recently, maybe
a long time ago,
of a technology that
helped you achieve
your purposes in your work for
remembrance and for justice
and for forgiveness.
EVA KOR: Well, it's an
interesting question.
I do not agree with
the word justice.
Only just punishment.
But I don't think there is
really justice in the world.
But purpose, I mean,
technology, I am not sure
if I am going to answer it.
How can I help using
technology in my philosophy
of forgiveness?
The Shoah Foundation
created holograms.
And I have a hologram of my own.
There are certain
survivors who were
recorded for hologram,
interactive holograms.
I think the idea that we
can spread the knowledge
and information
that each of us has.
And we can interact,
and by interacting, we
can help other people maybe
realize that they can do it too
in their own way.
I don't think that everybody
will do healing and forgiveness
in my way--
own way.
Technology-- I mean, he
created a wonderful film
with a lot of
technological parts.
And that we are also going to
make available for schools.
I do not know--
I will tell you one thing
that I'm fascinated.
I am fascinated by
all these questions.
Do you know that the
most interesting part
in the human body is the brain?
Everything that
we come up with--
I mean, I'm amazed how long
ago, over 100 years ago,
people came up with ideas.
Columbus discovered America.
The curiosities that we have.
We can do anything.
Therefore, I am convinced
that we can heal
all the problems in the world.
If I just gave you
an assignment here,
every single one of you,
if you ever are bored,
just think for 10
minutes, what can I
do to make the world better?
I don't care how little it is.
But every single one
of you can do something
to make the world better.
Now, if we can use
technology to enhance that,
that is where the
power of technology is.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
TED GREEN: Can I jump
in on this one as well?
I don't think
you're going to find
many more technology savvy
84-year-olds than this women
right here.
I mean, she's got an app.
She tweets all the time.
And actually, she delivers
her lectures via Skype.
She gets requests from
all over the world.
So she really has
been, you know,
back in the days
in the 1980s, when
all of your typed-written
letters to every publication
around the country just asking
them to help with your story.
And here you are
and she is really
reaching all around the world.
EVA KOR: And I found my
typewriter, if I'm moving,
the old typewriter I
found in the garage.
TED GREEN: All right.
AUDIENCE: Hi, first
of all, my name
is Rina like your daughter's
name. that's really--
EVA KOR: Oh, wonderful.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for coming.
I wanted to ask so in terms of
the Holocaust, what happened
overall, like a
genocide and whatnot,
do you think that
we, as a globe,
have learned from
that terrible event,
or do you think that
there's still more to learn?
EVA KOR: I think that
technology and communication
and the internet and
I will tell you why.
For instance, as
we sit here, there
are many people in the world who
are suffering, lack of freedom,
lack of food, lack
of many things.
But it was New Year's
Eve, and I said, well,
I am not going to
go anywhere, but I
want to do something unique.
So I was going to help--
the Iranian issue
was on the news.
They talked about the protests.
Those people are living in
theocracy without any freedom.
It's hard for us to understand
because in the United States,
we really have the most freedom
that most people would have.
Economically, it's
very important,
because if you don't have food,
you cannot be very free, right?
If you don't have money to buy.
So we can, all of
us, do something
and in helping other
people in preventing--
I mean, how on earth that
Iran was able to protest?
The internet.
So I tweeted.
I tweeted.
I did the following.
I said 73, years ago, we
were dying in the Nazi camps,
and the world was silent.
And I got about 26 responses.
I didn't like it.
So I said, 73 years ago,
I was dying in Auschwitz,
and the world was silent.
And I no longer can be silent.
I want you to join with me
and tweet for freedom of Iran.
I got 17,000 responses.
So it pays to be dramatic.
But also the fact that they
entered me in direct mail,
they said, nobody
has their stories.
They didn't know
if their stories
were carried by the media.
And me tweeting helped them
find out that we knew about it.
Of course, they were arrested.
I don't know what their
destiny is right now.
But I don't think--
here and there I
get some direct mail
that we are still
planning something.
So this is a way I have
a little bit of doubt
that easily it
can be pulled off.
Because direct mail,
direct message,
cannot completely be eradicated.
The technology is
helping break through.
That people have not
learned their lesson,
that is another tragedy.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, Eva.
You seem to have an immense
liveliness and vitality.
And I just wonder where
do you get it from?
What drives you?
EVA KOR: Well, then
Mengele stood by my bed
and said that I had
only two weeks to live,
I was going to prove him wrong.
And I had been trying to prove
the world wrong ever since.
I don't know.
I feel I was in the
hospital a year ago in May,
and I was supposed to
give the big speech,
that it was a terrific
speech, about medicine
and law and the Holocaust.
OK, that's combined everything.
And I worked very hard on it.
And I was rushed into
the emergency room
for not being able--
my heart was in big trouble.
It wasn't beating
more than 0 to 40.
And he was there at
the emergency room.
I said, Ted, this is the
best speech I ever wrote.
He said, I talked
to the doctors.
Can I get two hours
off to give my speech?
And they said, no, what if you
die while you give the speech
and we don't have the equipment.
I said, oh, god, that too.
So Ted recorded it.
And then I rolled into
the operating room
to get my pacemaker,
and my recording
got a standing ovation.
But I didn't meet Elena Kagan.
So she was in the audience.
I couldn't meet her.
I said maybe she would come to
the hospital, but she didn't.
TED GREEN: It was
actually really something
because they were the
co-keynote speakers.
And I will have to say, no
offense to the Supreme Court
Justice, but Eva's
taped speech got
a much bigger round of applause
than Elena Kagan's did.
EVA KOR: So where do I--
I don't really know.
I think some of it is genetic.
Most of it probably
comes from my mother
who I don't think
she ever thought
she would be living
in a big farm
in a godforsaken little village.
And she found joy and
happiness in what she could.
And she loved her children.
And she loved being
the woman that she was.
As she was arguing with my
father about her [INAUDIBLE]
little daughters,
because my father--
we were religious,
very, Orthodox Jews.
And my father said,
oh, the girl just
need to get married and
have babies and that is.
My mother said, no, my girls
are going to get an education.
And she never gave up on that.
So as I was going to
college for 11 years,
every time I was struggling,
the voice of my mother
was ringing in my
ears, "My children
are going to get an education."
And her vitality,
and her joy, she
would iron my father's
shirt with an iron
that had the charcoal in it.
And she would put on the
radio to listen to the radio.
She was happy doing
what she was doing.
So find happiness
in any situation.
There is always-- you
can make your life happy
even when things look
desperate or not very good.
Find joy in something.
And I find joy in the fact
that I get up every morning,
and I say, I'm still alive.
Ah, that's very good.
And then I see what
can I do good--
what good can I do today?
And that, right away,
puts me in a good mood.
SPEAKER 1: We have time for
one more quick question.
AUDIENCE: I was really
struck by a comment by Ted
earlier where you
mentioned that there
have been so many
Holocaust stories,
so why is this one different.
The reason that that
struck me is recent surveys
have shown that as many
as 2/3 of millennials
don't know what Auschwitz is.
40% of Americans
don't know what it is.
So with all those stories
that have been told,
what are we doing wrong?
And why aren't those stories
resonating and spreading?
EVA KOR: That is--
I don't know if I
can answer that.
I think that the
curriculum in schools
have to include the idea
that history is important.
We are the product of the past.
And we have to rely on what
happened before to go forward.
This country was
founded, and we have
to learn the history
of this country.
So many Americans have
died in World War II.
So many millions of people
That has to be a pretty
big event in the world
to have a bigger chapter
in the high school
and junior high school books.
And why doesn't it?
Because it is an
important chapter.
And what do we learn from it?
I am hoping that if I
am successful enough
with Ted and with what we are
doing, that I can stimulate
more interest for more schools.
Because the schools are
controlled by school board,
and they decide
their curriculum.
So we are learning.
With my publisher, I have
been giving lot of lectures
to school board and
[? schools ?] to adopt my book.
And once they adopt my book,
they learn a little bit more
to teach it.
And it's a along--
it's a big effort.
It's not simple.
But I think your point is
very well made, that we
need to make a bigger effort.
And all of us.
Not only me.
So I ask you to join me.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
SPEAKER 1: So Ted, Eva,
thank you for being here.
Thank you for
sharing your story.
Again, if you want to
learn more about the film,
it's TheStoryofEva.com.
And so thanks for your time.
[APPLAUSE]